une opération qui demande beaucoup
d'efforts et d'attention
au sein de cet homme doit d'abord être
soulevée avant d'être scié
la poutre doit être réalisé à la
perfection étant donnée sa destination
le chantier de notre dame de paris
la pression elle se fait vraiment fort
c'est qu'on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
c'est à dire que mon ça peut arriver à
tout le monde de rater un beau mais là
on n'a pas le droit là c'est
une pièce un beau donc il faut toujours
être derrière la lame toujours regarder
vraiment être
au plus juste possible spécialisée dans
le traitement de grands arbres
l'entreprise woods sur mesure dans le
nord de la france a été sélectionné pour
un contrat inusité fournir des dizaines
d'autres qui serviront à reconstruire la
flèche cette pièce majeure ajouté à la
cathédrale au 19e siècle a été emporté
par les flammes il y a trois ans
g2 a fait 48 et donc là on en a encore
une trentaine à faire
a jusqu'à la fin du mois le chêne
traiter aujourd'hui une signification
particulière l'arbre qui a environ 180
ans a été coupée dans la forêt d'une
ville voisine
à l'instar d'autres communautés à
travers le pays la municipalité a décidé
d'en faire don à notre dame de paris
il ya un formidable mouvement de fierté
et c'est l'occasion de leur dire voyez
comme nature est belle voyez comme ce
chêne son grain est beau et il est
sélectionné et c'est un un peu une
partie d'eux-mêmes qui va se retrouver à
la capitale pour philippe sénat
menuisier ébéniste depuis près de 30 ans
le moment est particulièrement important
quand vient le temps d'aborder
l'héritage que laissera le travail
réalisé dans sa scierie l'émotion
s'invite dans la conversation on est
quand même parti au mois pour 2 300 dont
on va dire donc
au minimum j'espère plus donc on a
d'autres noms labo donc nos
petits-enfants d'entre nous
il faudra pas moins de mille chiens de
couper dans différentes régions france
pour reconstruire la charpente et la
célèbre flèche de notre dame de paris
cette partie des travaux doit débuter
l'année prochaine avant la réouverture
la cathédrale qui est toujours prévu
pour 2024 il sert à faible vit au clair
radio canada